on the medical watch an inhaler to
protect you from covet 19
think about it if the virus enters your
body through your nose and your eyes
will
could a vapor protect you denise joins
us live in studio with the details about
a new drug and development denise
yeah christian one of the things that
we've learned about this virus is it
works its way through the nasal passages
and then to the lungs
so the earliest point of entry is also a
possible passageway for this
experimental drug
which right now is called cronas now
researchers in chicago are using a human
enzyme to inactivate the virus the drug
is really a mixture of a couple of
different proteins one
strips the spike of its protective
coating leaving it exposed to the immune
system
and then the other is an ace2 receptor
which helps the drug
bind to the virus to inactivate the
spike protein we can
stop the infection of the of um of the
virus we are designing this treatment to
be
stable in aerosols so it can be
delivered through
to patients through inhalers that's
right through an inhaler similar to the
type of asthma patients might use
cronase can be prophylactic means it can
be inhaled it can be injected or even
swallowed as a pill
animal and ultimately human trials are
going to be the next step for this
inhaler now experts do want to remind us
though that we've had recent years
three different outbreaks of coronavirus
did you remember sars
mers and now covet 19. we were not
prepared for any of those diseases so
researchers hope that studies like this
inhaler will better prepare us for the
future